now to our projections and see what we
are able to say about the election now
that it is 730 we will pick up the
election map and see what we can add to
it as you know we have West Virginia
North Carolina and Ohio closing in just
15 seconds
what officially will we be able to say
about those states that is the question
North Carolina Ohio and West Virginia
and this is a very very exciting moment
where I am ready to tell you that West
Virginia not surprisingly is going to be
in the Donald Trump camp that is another
correct prediction from me which I will
highlight on my piece of paper here we
also have an update not at all
surprisingly both North Carolina and
Ohio are too close to call both North
Carolina and Ohio too close to call so
officially can we go back to the map
guys officially right now Donald Trump
building his lead 24 to 324 to 3 is the
official count right now I believe that
in the next 30 to 60 minutes we are
going to start getting some more data
not only from the states that are
closing but very importantly from the
states that have already closed and are
currently too close to call so I will
just sort of to talk it through
Washington Oregon California endo and
Hawaii we can absolutely put in the
Hillary Clinton camp and that that would
sort of put us at 81 to 24 in favor of
Hillary Clinton for the time being I
will leave those as not selected since
indeed those have not closed yet what
data do we have let's see if we can pick
up some of the early data that we have
from The Guardian election website you
will notice that Virginia is sort of a
light red right now
and the reason for that is that the
early numbers right now have swung in
favor of Donald Trump you will see that
right now Florida is light blue
according to the Guardian and that is
because depending on where you look
Hillary Clinton has somewhere between a
0.2 to 0.6 percent lead there but it is
very very early just a little bit of
data coming in from there so now that we
have this I say that we go back to the
phones and see who wants to talk to us 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is going to be the
number I'm gonna be completely upfront
with you guys I still have my map here
of 3 22 2 to 16 in favor of Hillary
Clinton but I am getting a little bit
scared by some of this data that is
coming in 6 1 7 8 3 0 4 7 5 0 is the
number do we have do we have a caller
right now we will see if we've got it
right we talked to Sam so we've got to
get our live number back on there 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 is the number and we will we
will we will take calls as they come in
Ben Dixon is going to be back we will be
checking in again with Sam cedar and do
we have our guests are being led in
downstairs is that right Rachel yeah
very cool we don't want people stuck
outside today oh there's max a lot of
people in the back today we've got quite
a quite a staff going on were there
people downstairs max there were okay
good that's good to know people are
people are coming in the pizza is also
here Wow okay so everything is happening
right now okay six one seven eight three
zero four seven five zero approaching
700 live viewers on the stream do we
have a call Pat we don't have a call yet
okay it we got okay let's take that
first call and see who it is name in
town let's start with that who's joining
us today so you're gonna want to turn on
me down because I'm hearing myself
feedback and that is a train wreck Oh
God it all started in the Israel when
Moses came down from Mount
yeah delivered this 120 Commandments to
those Jews yeah one juice you Moses we
should make up Africa and Moses said my
homie I've been seen to make down right
so that is computer voice conspiracy
theorists who doesn't believe that
Africa exists thank you thank you so
much yeah all right we can hang up on
them Pat that's I mean it's hot it's
always great to hear from computer voice
who doesn't believe Africa exists but we
do probably have other calls to get to 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number and we
will take maybe a call from a real
person wow I did not expect a call from
computer voice today Pat that is uh that
is always very very surprising people on
the stream incredibly confused very very
confused six one seven eight three zero
four seven five zero let's take the next
call and then after why don't we go to
our updated graphics of where the race
stands if we have it all right name in
town who's joining me via Skype today
hey this is Christian and were you
calling from Christian I'm in Vermont
you said you're in Vermont
yes all right what's on your mind today
uh well obviously the mall just called
for Hillary Clinton
as expected I just wanted to tell you
with all the sort of stress and turmoil
and causing people yeah I really found
that your show has been not only
informant for probably not just me for a
lot of people but it also gives me a
sense of because of that information
also makes me feel more safe it's re
you're sort of breaking up a little bit
you said you're saying the show is
making it all feel more serious stay
safe okay well listen I wish that I felt
the same way because I do have my piece
of paper in front of me that says
Hillary 322 Trump 216 but some of these
early numbers
I admit are not exactly inspiring huge
confidence I hope they're safe but I
don't know that's not what I meant I see
okay
I mean Stace isn't like I uncomfortable
going on about me even though some
people really stressed out you know I
mean yeah all right well I really really
do appreciate that very always hear from
people in Vermont and we will I hope
you'll keep watching and listening thank
you so much to everybody joining us on
the stream and we will let's see if
we've got another call here as we move
on six one seven eight three zero 47 50
by the way is the number remember we are
trying to get to a thousand viewers
that's our initial goal on the live
stream please share the stream on
Twitter Facebook reddit anywhere that
you can who's joining me next from
California Jessie what's up what's on
your mind today I just want to say love
your show
thank you keep up the great work
alright any question or comment or
that's it for you today correct respect
alright alright concise short and sweet
I like it Jesse from California thank
you so much six one seven eight three
zero
4750 is the number we are about twenty
two minutes away from the next results
eight o'clock is a big big hour and we
will get to those results eventually
who's next on the phone with Mary hello
you're on the air okay hi do you think
the delay with this I was trying to turn
down the street and I apologize for how
prom what's on your mind additions for
you two very important questions
longtime viewer one why isn't the people
you just ordered pineapple and bacon I
don't eat pork number two and I number
two is will we hear Louis just chime in
with his opinions will we get to have
that special treatment
you know I texted Louis earlier today
and said hey just join us on the live
stream for a little bit and he said he's
involved in trivia tonight so I I don't
know if Lewis is going to be able to
join us
but it would be great to hear from him
but he is going to be involved in trivia
tonight so that's that's what the deal
is with Lewis thank you so much for the
call really really appreciate it